[ __ ] it up to the jillion podcast
there's no one to offer a high-five over
no high-five exactly I like when people
send us those gifts are like what the
guest feels like and it's like that lady
from family feud with her entire family
event over yeah yeah we had a nice
little Street there three weeks of
guests in a row yeah so it's good to be
back just just us two having it out J&J
style cheer missed you
hey how you doing I'm good how are you
we are yeah we're back guys thanks for
watching
so we had an idea for this week to talk
about something that's pretty relevant
just because of the event this weekend
and near and dear to our heart and near
and dear to our I think this makes the
third podcast that we've had about the
UFC yes in some capacity in some
capacity not to mention the other ones
where we just make references and or
talk about it which is like everybody's
like my analogies always circle around
music trip but yeah we wanted to talk
about the UFC as its own kind of subject
and stuff going on you know with in the
UFC right now and the organization as a
whole but we also wanted to discuss the
amazing and hugely popular Ronda Rousey
hmm so I guess we could start off with
the UFC yeah because there are some
things happening right yeah it's worth
talking about I think for those who
don't know the UFC is the Ultimate
Fighting Championship it is the major
player in terms of organizations for
mixed martial arts which is fighting
that we are big fans of phone iPhone
pipefish and we've been fans that you
see forever yeah we're a fan before I
even met you and I'm a fan before you
met me and I guess the main thing that
we wanted to touch on is there's been a
lot of changes recently in the UFC so to
give a bit of a crow
if I might please the UFC it's centered
around the structure of sponsorships
before recently and what I mean by that
is that fighters athletes who were
employed by the UFC were able to
independently go out and get their own
sponsors companies brands one who ever
wanted to sponsor that fighter who ever
liked what that fighter was about and
would be willing to pay them in order
them in order for them to wear their
brand on say their fight shorts or their
walkout shirt or their banner banners no
longer exist now I think maybe actually
I think I feel like I've seen them but
it just has like their picture and in
social media and Reebok yeah yeah and so
it's such a big deal
is that the way it was fighters didn't
have to solely rely on just the money
they like money paid for fighting
there's fight money there's show money
and then there's win money and there's
of course bonuses right so for instance
say I'm a lower you know one of the
younger newer fighters to the
organization say I'm getting and these
figures are completely off my dome like
I don't know anything about gets paid
what but saying I'm a newer fighter the
UFC and I get $20,000 to show up in
$20,000 to win so if I just lose but I
show up and make way and everything I
get $20,000 but if you think about it
I'm not getting all that money I got to
pay my trainers right I got to pay
everyone who basically my team who
helped me get to the point of stepping
into the Octagon for the fight and what
helps is getting paid a lot of money not
a lot but a lot more money than nothing
from sponsors right
recently the UFC has signed an exclusive
deal with Reebok for their apparel for
everything so now fighters no longer get
to have the opportunity of going out and
getting their own sponsors everyone's
sponsored by Reebok so it's busy you
have seen a UFC so if your EFC fighter
you are under the Reebok umbrella now
you wear Reebok Reena shorts all the
shorts are the same now which which that
is also kind of interesting because a
lot of people just wore their favourite
types of shorts or their favourite gear
and thighs they know they can't write
so I think the biggest thing and I think
the there's this is completely objective
here and I'm just pointing out the fact
that MMA fans aren't super happy with a
lot of the Reebok deal and I think the
reason for that is that the UFC has put
the fighters in a situation where they
either need to escalate up the rankings
very very fast or not fighting the UFC
in terms of making a living right
because some of these fighters are not
getting paid enough to do what they do
not even comfortably but just not at all
which is a little ridiculous because the
UFC has enough money to be paying people
you know their livings for them to stay
and be happy yeah this is kind of a
choice on the UFC's part and who's to
say really what's going on if this is
Reebok that structuring sale in a way
that was unfair to subside Laura fitly
nobody do you know that I think right
and I think maybe it was just a
combination of a lot of things that led
to this not being the greatest deal ever
for independent people but I mean just
think of it this way for those of you
that aren't you know super into UFC or
MMA and that kind of thing
think of like a NASCAR not a car like
they're covered in sponsors it's the
culture of this war right it was sort of
the culture of sport in the UFC to be
sort of covered in sponsors and now you
haven't talked like touched on this yet
but the the guy that puts like the
Vaseline on their faces what stitch yeah
stitch - ran the cut man the heel why
don't you get into that yeah really
quickly though you mentioned that
NASCAR's you know and drivers imagine
they just stripped everybody's sponsors
away in every box car yeah the thing
about that is the thing about them hold
on the thing the UFC isn't done with
sponsors the fighters are so look at the
Octagon the floor that they fight on it
is faster than sponsors right there's a
monster energy there's movies there's
all sorts of stuff that the UFC is now
getting sponsored by so that means you
would I don't know for sure but I guess
that means that the UFC is pocketing
that well no one else the sponsorship
money not the fighters yeah so
so it will be one thing if you know and
I'm not saying this is a good thing but
it would be one thing if the UFC was
like you know what no more sponsors were
changing the culture of the sport and
the Octagon was plain there was no
sponsors anywhere right that's one thing
but the UFC is continuing to have those
on the floor so it is a little
conflicting and it's confusing because
it does seem it comes off selfish
it comes off greedy when you look at
that cuz it's like okay then the UFC is
getting sponsor money well because
there's plenty of fighters that have
used their voices loudly to say that
it's not benefiting them in particular
and that is the biggest reason why fans
are upset because they're seeing
firsthand on Twitter these fighters
literally just say I am broke yeah I
used to make money on sponsors all my
sponsors who have developed
relationships with for years because
that takes a while sponsorships that
trust you to pay you more money each
fight to develop relationships and now
that's all gone that's off the table
with the reward because think of
Demetrius Mighty Mouse Johnson he used
to only be sponsored by Xbox yes which
is which was dealer because he was the
only one that had a sponsor like that
like that just just your shorts just say
Xbox like Jon Jones in his prime when he
was here
Nike right and was that Anderson Silva
just Burger King and Nike and Nike
like it's a serious status symbol to not
be covered in ten sponsors but like one
huge sponsor yeah it's it comes in now
that you're getting paid fairly do you
know what I mean for that them to just
sell out their entire shorts their
entire brand to just Xbox you just
burger Kane just Nike yeah and we do run
remind you guys that we love the UFC we
have great contacts and we are of a
great relationship with UFC so this is
this is us purely just speaking our
minds and what what's going on because
if we were to talk about the UFC and
just ignore this it wouldn't be doing
you guys right it's you know it's not
being honest and that's what this
podcasts about but I do want it you
mentioned stitch the guy who stands on
the side of the Octagon and puts
Vaseline on the fighters faces before
the fight and comes in between rounds to
fix their cuts they're swelling
basically allow the fight to go past one
round
his name was stitch that was his
nickname Duran and he was the UFC come
in for a long time and the UFC fired him
after he spoke out about not being able
to wear sponsors on his cut me invest
after the Reebok deal happened and I
know that there's more to it than people
know there has to there has to be but it
didn't look good and people like who if
you're a fan of the sport you were a
hundred percent automatically a fan of
stitch direct you can't not like him
he's a happy guy every fighter loves him
he does an incredible job keeping fights
going like people will have cuts and
stuff that you're like they stopped the
fight he'll come in between rounds and
fix it up I don't know how but he he's
the best of the best and it was
upsetting for a lot of them and my fans
to watch stitch go down like that
after all we saw he did was hey I can't
make money on sponsors Reebok is only
paying me this amount when before I
could control how much I was making and
for a guy like said she can't have
another job like he can't have a
full-time job and be the cup man he has
to be that so the good thing I would say
looking forward is the read-back deal
will end it has to it's going to end any
the UFC will remain yeah change it or
the break it out cuz I think that the
amount of backlash has been good because
anybody in any profession ever say you
have the ability to like in theory
control how much money you make yeah do
you I mean if you want more money and
you create more sponsorships for
yourself and you do that legwork to get
that done yeah you can make more money
you in theory have you know a ladder to
climb more control aside from just how
well you do in fights when you take that
ability away from people like you you
give them a cap you give them a ceiling
nobody likes having their options taken
away no one likes having flexibility
taken away from their job if especially
if they're used to it that's wrong day
one absolutely you know what I mean and
I think that the people that are
speaking out in a way that's
constructive is helping yeah because I
don't obviously you know you can scream
from the mountains that you pissed the
[ __ ] off and [ __ ] but there are some
people that have made some really great
points yes that I think will be taken
very seriously because in theory the
only reason why this sponsorship like
total takeover sponsorship
happened is if every single person it's
affecting is making more more money
right not drastically less not less
money uh there was an open letter on for
those hardcore MMA fans you know what
the underground is it's a website blog
forum it's been around for years it's
least I know what you're gonna say
already it's gonna make me laugh more
that guy's late he was talking about
what their show yeah no it was basically
the open letter it was to Dana White the
president of the UFC and the open letter
was from a fan and he just this
long-winded wall of text explaining why
he speaks for the fans and saying that
he's upset with the Reebok deal and he
did it in the most polite and respectful
way possible and he prefaced everything
with Dana I'm a huge fan of you I am
very very lucky as an MMA fan to be in a
sport that you have largely created you
know a foundation for and then he goes
on to say you know and he glazes over a
little bit the fighters they pay because
I think he just didn't know too much
about that which is true not a lot of
people know exactly like his got details
but he did talk about how seeing his
favorite fighters like tell the world
that they can't afford to train they
can't afford to have his camper stuff
like that is very weird and it's
shocking for a fit and it's not
something that that fan can look at and
be happy about and what she was saying
is they they now have fighter kits which
is a shirt and shorts like gear that
they wear to fight nights and before
literally that was up to anyone [ __ ]
what's his name there was one fighter
I'm blanking on his name he's old-time
fire he showed up one time in a speedo
and he fought in a speedo like the rules
were that rigid not saying that you
should do that and I was there for that
fight actually well remember in the
beginning of the UFC they were allowed
to fight in their gi's and whatever the
follow yeah that was no there was
regulations like you had shorts you had
spandex there's somewhat regulation now
not prior to the Reebok proper to the
uniforms there were regulations thing
you can wear
very few amount of things but the point
I bring you take could wear skirts you
wanted to wear fights skirts you could
wear like the man now you don't you have
no exact Reebok rebuttal spandex or
board shorts now and they're all black
and white well they're not black yeah
they're black and white yeah yeah just
their gloves the tape red and blue but
that's just the corner so yeah it would
be you know looking at a fight now
compared to before the Reebok deal it
just looks more corporate which is you
know it's fine if you if the idea is to
change the way the sport looks make it
look more official give them uniforms
that's fine
there's nothing wrong with that innately
just make sure that when you're doing
that the fighter pay doesn't at least
get so drastically affected that the
fighters are tweeting you know yeah
because us as fans and them as fighters
this is their professional job you pay
fifty to seventy-five dollars a
pay-per-view or whatever luck and if you
want to go see in person it's not cheap
and we do that on a regular basis as
fans yeah so that these people hopefully
in theory can do nothing every single
waking moment of their life but be the
best physical fighter that they can yeah
you know and then go get your money and
do whatever you want absolutely but the
position that this is putting these
people in is that they're having to get
really crafty in ways to make extra
income that they are now missing yeah
and I don't want that nobody wants that
what he wants you guys to train I want
you to be busy train do your job and and
do what you want to do because we want
to see people fight at their best
ability exactly plus it's it's less of a
sport now and it's more of like we're
watching these guys at work and they're
all desperate and it's like well it
doesn't feel like the same it did right
well it also creates a lot of room for
desperation like people begging to get
more work well you see it too often guys
that's a big knockout they'll get on the
mic and say hey how about that bonus now
and it's like as a fan you like that
that don't look great you know it's like
a that desperate right now while people
are they need their [ __ ] money man
these people have short careers in
theory oh yeah you know you're lucky
what I would love to have a some
statistic but I know the statistics for
you know people even making it to a
college sport let alone an elite
like this your chances of having a
career over one year professionally in
football that's like a ridiculous like
if you're fighting for 10 years that's
just absolutely insane so if you think
these people have been broke broke broke
for their road leading up to getting
signed with UFC finally amazing they
finally make it these people can be
riddled with injuries other things you
just don't make it I mean it's just
mathematically the odds are stacked
against you yeah you're now giving these
people the they know that their career
in theory might not be that long yeah
they need to make as much money as they
can right now and you've taken away
their ability to cash in while they can
absolutely it's I would be pretty
[ __ ] desperate to well be thinking
about it like this it's like you're a
minor league baseball player for years
and years and years and years and you
finally get the call up and you get a
contract with the Angels like you're not
getting paid chump change you're making
money and once you're up there right and
they tell me major league isn't it just
if you're on the bench of a [ __ ]
actual team it's three hundred to four
hundred thousand dollars a year yeah but
that's for contracts when you get called
up you might not have a contract course
on but yeah it's the point is is it
seems like a lot of money until you
realize that you know in a year from now
you're back down and if you would like
to eat it right you need that money I
want to I want to say that the UFC has
done so many things right in their time
agreed I'm super busy right then wrong
they've so much more right than wrong
and I think this is a hiccup that in a
couple years hopefully we can look back
on and say I'm glad we steered away from
that right but there's one thing that I
think is an existing Reebok was tweeting
them out like pictures of their shirts
with God there was like I don't know I
want to say like eight misspelled names
on these Official Fighter kits and these
fighters were tweeting like you would
see fighters being like hey that's my
kid not how you spell my name there was
a Gil Ramon Dez the his said Gibbler and
in a Twitter account came up to Gilbert
Gilbert Melendez
was that picture she was felt Gilbert it
says Gibbler oh my god the Twitter cow
came up and he's just like a troll now
he's like so glad you asked about my
fight kid says my name I don't know who
made the skip up there but that getting
out was it it was just a bad look is
like it showed whoever was responsible
maybe Reebok maybe someone at the UFC
who knows just be a really tired intern
who knows the point is is they went went
for it and they release those and it
just looked that it was like the first
thing Reebok had put out and it was like
wow yeah certainly doesn't send again
yeah
president but I think that in theory the
idea of having the entire UFC have one
single sponsor for everyone it's not
about age no it's not if you're trying
to move away from the look of having
your sponsors plastered all and I mean
imagine how difficult it is for everyone
to manage all of their own sponsors and
the UFC to do that regular base yeah
that's like you know what anybody does
that you know even with the podcast so
it took to go through the legwork to get
to get the sponsors it's not easy and
it's not short working I'm sure that's
you know a team of people's full-time
job at the UFC to decide which sponsors
are going where oh yeah and to just have
all of that be wiped away for the
opportunity to just do one big huge deal
yeah is like a dream come true do you
know what I mean yeah and I don't think
I don't think that it's a bad idea and I
I would like to say that there's no harm
in them trying this with Reebok but it
is harm people it did harm to lose
incomes and you know some people
suffered because of it yeah but I think
in the future if they choose to tweak
this deal and make sure that it's more
fair for people but it's not a bad thing
to have the entire everything sponsored
by one sponsor yeah absolutely
absolutely because it could work there's
enough money to go around yeah I mean
between Reebok in the UFC you can make
sure that people can feed their families
okay and we're not talking like hundred
thousand dollar paychecks for every
fighter every fight no we're talking
about enough to make sure that they can
cover their campaign they can pay their
coaches pay their rent
you know is now they're walking a
delicate line of people considering
leaving and going to other organization
which which is something good for
anybody UFC knows that well it's good
for lots of people and people should
have choices I think that's really
important yeah but it's not helping the
UFC no I mean by giving people a reason
to leave that's not the goal yeah yeah
and and I think what you said about the
fact that it would be nice to say and
sit here right now that it did no harm
didn't harm it did do I hate to do harm
but you know what that doesn't mean the
UFC really [ __ ] up that means the UFC
took a misstep on a lot of people's
opinions and they can move forward in a
more constructive way learning from this
you know learning maybe maybe Reebok
isn't that maybe the way we structure
this deal wasn't in our in our best
interest and on our fighters ventures
best interest and in turn our image it's
the best interest but it doesn't make me
think poorly of Reebok or the you
neither of them because you don't know
what's going on so many moving parts so
many people involved honestly it could
have been something as easy as under
estimating how much money fighters made
that's absolutely possible that's
absolutely ideal and all right let's do
it
yeah that's a hundred percent so many
other bigger things to consider in terms
of an entire branded thing yeah and you
know what another thing is that people
who change the game people who are
renegades who make very big waves and
leave a legacy you know in their wake
when they're done they don't do
everything right always and I would like
to say that the UFC is among that class
they have done so much good for the
sport of MMA when they signed the Fox
deal sure there weren't great things
about that but there was also amazing
things about that that broke them more
into the mainstream than they've ever
become they were on Fox Sports they now
are on Fox and so what I'm getting is is
that the UFC you know if they are the
organization that I believe them to be
and a lot of people do believe them to
be they're going to move past this in a
more in a more directional and positive
route than they could have ever done
without having to gone and go through
this mess you know they're gonna take it
and use it to their advantage and who
knows you know maybe something this is
just I'm [ __ ] throwing [ __ ] out there
yeah who knows maybe Nike is sitting
around laughing at this Reebok deal and
then once this contract is up they swoop
in and they're like hey guys we'd like
to pay everyone a shit-ton bop tongue oh
my god that's well that Nike did that to
Reebok at the CrossFit Games there you
go do you know what they did did you
hear about this I'm not a hundred
percent sure of the logistics but you
are more than welcome to tell me okay so
Nike created a shoe called the metcon
which is their first
CrossFit shoe they broke into the cross
and market with the metcon and everyone
wanted everyone in there mom wanted even
all the hardcore crossed some people who
are a hardcore Reeboks
who wear the nanos which is the Nano
shoe or which is sorry the Reeboks
version of CrossFit shoe anyway at the
CrossFit Games
Nike parked their giant [ __ ] van or
something big bus outside of the
CrossFit Games because the CrossFit
Games bans Nike response by Reebok
exclusively so no no competitors could
wear the Nike MAG car and they had a big
sign that says don't ban our shoe beat
it and it was like really funny because
you know this is a whole like marketing
war now between what but it's just
really funny because I mean that sucks
for them but it's fun for all of us it's
fun for everyone yeah when people can be
like that but you're right there could
be bigger brands who are like you know
what we can do this way better let's
wait our turn you know but ya know III
think it's good that we talked about it
I think it's on our minds every time we
watch a fight now something's different
so can you please already tell them what
that guy's ok so the guy the guy in the
open letter I'm quoting him but it might
not be exactly what he said but he in
the open letter to Dana White he gets to
the part where he's talking about the
UFC fighter kids and he said it looks
like the fighters are now a cross
between an ice cream popsicle and a new
no deck because they do look like oh no
decks yeah they do they do yeah well
moving on right you go I want to talk
about Ronda Rousey briefly Ronda Rousey
who everyone
ever now knows her name which is awesome
has has just completely broken into the
next level of damadam the entire [ __ ]
division aside from the fact that she's
completely wrecked everyone she's fought
and no one can even come close right now
she's reached a point of stardom that
GSP took years to reach that Spyder
Anderson Silva took years to reach and
even they I don't think crossed over to
where Ronda has crossed over she's
breaking barriers regardless of gender
regardless of everything she's she's
changing you know so many things and so
many good things come of what Ronda
Rousey has done it's very interesting to
see it's very awesome to see because you
know for a while she came across as this
kind of standoffish like kind of I'm not
going to talk to you I'm just gonna do
my fighting there and that got her a lot
of haters I guess you could say people
were like oh Ron is a [ __ ] like why
would I like her but she kept with it
and it was like you know she proved she
really did prove her worth in fighting
and winning and destroying everyone and
then slowly warming up and being like
you know what this is who I am guys
right deal with it enjoy it and now
everyone [ __ ] I'm not here to
entertain you I'm literally that much of
a professional where I just I [ __ ] off
and she's the most professional there is
she was in the Olympics she wanted
bronze medal in judo [ __ ] insane how
much of a professional people don't
understand what that means she makes
people around her just look like
chickens with their heads cut off even
Jon Jones
she's making him look like the biggest
mockery of like the top of the top how
he acts because of how she's a complete
professor right and you know people call
her you know standoffish or those kind
of things until they realized now that
all of their other idols have fallen to
the wayside because the stupid [ __ ]
they've done I guess maybe I should take
her seriously because
that's a great that's a great thing
because ridiculously seriously she's
taking herself so seriously shows and
give people an option now and it was
only a matter of time before people
started realizing what she was about I
like to tell the story oh that because
you miss yeah so I like to tell her
sorry
because Ronda Rousey was buckin born I
like to pride myself on knowing about
certain certain people just a handful of
people before they were absolutely
massive I used to do a radio show in
college where it was called fighting
solo radio that's how good it was still
around can we still hear that I have all
of them you do I have all of them on my
drive because you've interviewed some
incredible people thank you yeah yeah I
mean I would say they're pretty cool
people but yeah basically interviewed
fighters and people in the sport of MMA
all through college on this radio show
and Ronda was nice enough to come on the
radio show via phone interview but
before that in January of 2012 I believe
I was in this in the business or hobby I
guess you could say I wasn't getting
paid of blogging and covering MMA events
like local MMA events I would go put on
my tie take my camera take my recorder
and go to local events and see who I can
interview see if I can watch the
write-ups always on my side and I went
to this one fight in Santa Monica it was
called I can't remember I can't remember
what it was called I'll remember later
but it was a local fight promotion I got
contacted with the promoter and he was
like yeah sure come by we'll give you a
press pass and I was like [ __ ] yeah
anytime I got a press pass I was like
yes sweet anyway she was there and at
the time Ronda was in Strikeforce she
had a couple fights in Strikeforce but I
think she'd just beat Julia bud which is
one of one of the first fights people
look started to notice her she broke her
own and she's sitting cage side because
she's just the guest of the event and I
somehow I was with my brother Marlon I
was like my uncle trying to get Rhonda
so I somehow sneak over at the time she
was dating Henry Aikens was a jutsu guy
he got up from his chair next to her so
I took it and I was like hey Rhonda can
i chat with you really quick I loved it
have a conversation and she was like
yeah have a seat right my boyfriend's
chair sounds like
oh [ __ ] so I sat down I had a great
conversation with her she went to my
high school by the way anyway we had a
great talk it was so cool to have a
conversation with her she later agreed
to come on my radio show so I promise
she probably does remember me but I've
had two interviews with Ronda before
even 2012 there's a picture of her and
you from behind of you guys should I
should post that that's like it's pretty
[ __ ] at this yeah it's it was cool
photo credit to Marlon for that one
Marla's just back there with his phone
like oh shoot man shoot man but yeah
it's it's like having been in that
position and you know I have a good
friend Mark who's who's been my MMA
buddy forever and when I told him about
that he was like you have no idea how
big of a deal that is she wasn't a big
deal and he was you don't have big big
of idea that is that you just did that
right now and I'd like to say he was
right because she's absolutely blown up
the rock is always talking about her
she's the biggest of the biggest now and
it's very very cool to see what she's
accomplished in the sport and it beyond
right you know she's done amazing things
and that fight holy [ __ ] yeah did you
notice that at the weigh-ins boetker
hair was was yelling she was yelling
they translated her what she was saying
don't cry when I knock you out
so when Ron and knocked her out she
turned around and said don't cry it was
like perfect it was like you can't write
that she didn't cry though she didn't
cry but she did it was perfect good
listening that's good listening that's
didn't cry I saw obviously you know I
can't say enough about Rhonda it's just
[ __ ] incredible
to watch her win that fight without you
know she had her in a position where she
was gonna cheat in judo she was
literally gonna you know flip her with
some [ __ ] judo magic yeah and didn't
she chose not to she had her completely
in the clinch exactly like it would take
three seconds of her magical gravity
hips to toss her and she didn't and she
knocked her out anyway so it's
completely mind-blowing and ridiculous
but what I was gonna say is that Sonja
Hawks like I saw her on Instagram a
picture of Ronda Rousey split with
Brienne of Tarth
this is the only logical own it yeah I
can't think of who else except for side
work but I still think she'll wreck side
work crews cyborgs has said she would
literally die if she dropped her mother
that Tommy talk it was that Dana white
recording of him sitting in their time
that was literally what Dana said yeah I
was saying that shake literally died
she's gonna do it alright yeah I'm like
I was like crying but what I want to
know what I'm more interested in
especially like I know you're a little
bit more removed from like the
underground of all that because you used
to be so far into it when you're doing
the radio show you know now you have
other things that you do as opposed to
getting people on your college radio
station yes which is everything epic
what are the first time we met you were
on the phone Shayna Baszler I'm like
what the [ __ ] is our gonna say okay well
I'm interested in is who in the [ __ ] is
training right now as a female that
could even like you know we talked about
Rory MacDonald and some of the fighters
that come up learning and then they as a
whole young set up coming some who and
the female doing that right now one
particular fight background because
Holly Holm is that her name yeah she's a
kpop kid right she's nasty she's not
exactly the new breed of like MMA
fighter out she's not Rory MacDonald or
anything like that yeah I know I'm just
saying like she's someone that has some
clout page have some clout but I'm
interested to see like a new breed of
female fighter that might be able to
yeah come up in the world in the sport
because what the [ __ ]
touch her I want to know who they're
they're 12 year old self has been worse
like completely inspired by Ronda and
it's like I'm gonna do that well telling
12-year olds are there I'll tell you one
thing send in my way whatever they are
whatever however around you know
rounding their game out they are with
MMA they're definitely doing judo oh
everybody's doing everybody it's like it
was like five years ago when people were
like holy [ __ ] if you have a background
in wrestling you were gonna be a
kick-ass fire
everyone was like I need a view
background wrestling
everyone resolutions GSP just learned
wrestling on his own college [ __ ]
wrestling background in his gym no no
GSP did that after like his gymnastics
training yeah yeah yeah oh my god GSP
and his [ __ ] gymnastics answer your
question it's a very it's it's vast and
I would love to do more research and to
look into it because I love that [ __ ]
into finding who's who's really
up-and-coming right now because
obviously people have been talking about
Holly Holm forever and she's a kickboxer
but she hasn't really proved to be
devastating agreed so although I'm sure
she'll have a fantastic career no matter
what happened she already is she's
fighting great fights as well lots of
other female fighters but I have a
question for you because you know do you
think that Ronda will retire undefeated
no no no no I don't think she'll do I
think she'll lose before she retired
retired I mean she was like what if she
decided to do Gina Carano and go to
Hollywood I mean yeah it's not like she
can't do other things she can do
whatever she wants at this point you
know I just I I think the rete the
reason I say yes she's probably gonna
lose before she retires is because even
Jon Jones like gets beaten up some you
know to me even some of the best of the
best fighters so she's gonna eventually
fight someone I think hopefully if she's
in the sport long enough which I
desperately hope she is where they catch
her with a couple punches and she's off
her game and then suddenly you know she
lost and and I think that losses what if
she just decided like hey it's been real
and I'd like to retire undefeated
because that's banana it's bananas but
that's rare that's so rare that's even
more rare than someone like Ronda coming
around so I would be like holy [ __ ] if
that happened that's insane amazing I
mean I don't think just considering the
way that everything's gone now do you
think that it's impossible for the next
10 years she meets zero opponents that
can beat her and she ends up just you
know out of necessity or age or whatever
yeah she retires on I guess you're right
I guess that's feasible because I think
that it's fees I think it's feasible
mm-hmm if I were to if I'm a betting man
I would say she loses before she retires
but no I think that's just I'm more than
possum oh no no sure
cyborg is not going to be any problem I
love when Rhonda tweets that cyborg like
hey get off the roids and we'll fight
like get off the rise and make way and
let's [ __ ] fight it's just so funny
Ron against no [ __ ] well thank you
Rhonda for an incredible weekend and
something to talk about on the podcast
fantastic fantastic I feel like she's
fighting every two weeks also which is
badass
it's so badass but that's you know again
speaks to her level of professionalism
and her [ __ ] her elite elite elite
athleticism like no one can do that yeah
so yeah cuz I mean what is she well she
looks like she might walk around it like
155 yeah and she can be ready to fight
every two weeks at 135 it's just not
only that but she takes zero damage
every fight she's she's just like got
out of the shower after a fight like are
you okay yeah I'm fine like I didn't
even get touched I got punched once but
it felt like someone elbowed me yeah
like on the way to the subway but yeah
I'm definitely excited to see both the
direction the UFC goes and also the
direction they take in terms of finding
[ __ ] for Ronda to do you know right well
yeah if you're just hanging out and you
know you don't kind of fight coming up
just hang out with us come on the
podcast like well is she's just gonna
rematch everybody well I think they're
talking about a meet you Tate third
fight which I don't necessarily think is
great but if there's enough I want at
least I wanna lose Carmouche rematch
yeah we were there for that that lady's
got a fight that was the first fight she
grabbed her back and was attempting a
rear naked chokehold standing up and she
like choke somebody out just a few
rounds before like that right didn't he
wasn't at your I favor yeah I'm trying
to remember he choked out I'm forgetting
everyone's name he's the Canadian he
trains with GSP yeah his name but yeah
he did the same standing rear naked
chokehold and then Liz Carmouche climbs
her like a little monkey and got back
there and rotted got out but Jenna you
love this car I do
she's a baller I love loose Carmouche
because she gives no [ __ ] she's like
yeah dude you just was in the military
right nobody
he was giving her even the slightest
because she had nothing to lose yes
everything's again she went into that
fight exactly like yeah and she was a
pleasure to watch her yeah try and choke
out Ronda yeah but it was it was just so
legit it was very exciting yeah well I'm
sorry if you guys are like sitting there
and like what are they talking about
because I feel like there's some of you
who are probably like that but we wanted
to do this podcast and I'm happy to be
dead well yeah because I really like
this I love this stuff I'll forever be a
fight fan and hopefully for every UFC
fan I love them so much
but yeah I'm very uh I'm very curious to
see what unfolds next you know we're
where they go and King John Jones get
his [ __ ] together because I wanna see
him fight again yeah seriously I'm over
his [ __ ] ticks over your life your
antics are getting in the way of my
Saturday nights right I want to see you
elbow people I want to see you beat
Daniel Cormier again isn't do career
fighting Alexander gusterson's yeah when
is that we had an entire podcast I was
talking about okay so Daniel Cormier
John Jones murders him like three
seconds inside of the Octagon again he
dies is it murder so funny that was like
our second lawyers we do not become
lawyers in law we became [ __ ] like
idiots no we were like the smartest
lawyers in the world we're like oh if he
says I could you like two steps up onto
the Octagon he's liable for one of those
three steps too close to the fight then
it's premeditated yeah no yeah we were
experts in the law oh yeah it's just so
experienced yeah well thanks for tuning
in thank you guys for hanging out with
us this week good podcast
let us know your thoughts about Ronda
Rao
let us know your thoughts about the UFC
um yeah the UFC the sponsorship and
where you see the future of that
contract with them going yeah for sure
you know where you see Ronnie's future
going and if you know any badass like
twelve-year-old girls like I would love
to interview a 12 year old [ __ ]
little girl I'm a maked there was a
young judo player judoka who was like I
think 12 she was and there was like
videos floating around of her and she
was pretty incredible like a couple
years ago so I wonder where she is yeah
we should not not that it matters if
she's 12 or 21 but you know young prime
know not even that because like people
get burnt out that's what they say like
you know people that have been doing
sports ever since they're retired long
as the exception to the rule
burn out yeah yeah but even still if she
did you know her entire life and then
she changed sports and theater so it's
like a refreshing right so that's like
saying if you did gymnastics for ten
years you might get burned out of
gymnastics but if you became a diver it
would be beneficial that's a good
analogy but the statistics of people
burning out that start when they're
super young because that you know
parents stupid [ __ ] may run their
kids into the ground of burning them out
so young so that not necessarily needs
to be twelve I wouldn't mind if it was
like a 21 year old girl there someone
that was committed to and wanted to
because there's like it's difficult to
find people to even have similar
mindsets they're on the road yeah they
say it but I'm not buying it you want to
see these girls right through college
that's a quote from the office I'm so
sorry without okay I can't even get
through a day you guys don't even know
I'm saying things like what do you say
it's an office or it's a syndrome I am I
have it I can't help
it's okay it's good well I've seen a lot
of the office that I don't like I don't
know all the references I have a problem
alright guys make sure you check out our
guests website we'll link it below
thanks for coming on the podcast good
podcast we love you guys we're on
soundcloud itunes all the stuff we'll
see you next week for another pop cast
and obviously hit us in the comments let
us know he thought his podcast and I
love you guys
bye